the double life of count Galeazzo
channel actually managed to say Ray Ray
has been a foreign correspondent for the
past three decades and is currently the
chief foreign correspondent for the
Chicago Tribune in 1981 he was the
runner-up for the Pulitzer an
international reporting and he will be
reading from and discussing his new book
which is right up here and judging from
conch Chanos penchant for intrigue
scandal and abuse of power it should be
quite an interesting discussion there
will be time for questions following his
reading that sort of thing and he'll
sign books afterwards so I'm pleased to
present ray Mosley
Thank You Amanda for the introduction
I'm not going to talk too long I'd like
to talk a bit about the book and about
how I came to write it and then get your
questions I'd much rather have your
questions and hear the sound of my own
voice but Galeazzo Chano is a not a
household name today of course but he
was a crucial figure in in the in the
central event of the 20th century
history which was the rise of
totalitarianism and in europe and which
led on to world war ii cost lost my
train of thought here that that was not
the principle or not the only reason
that I I was interested in writing this
book the I was equally intrigued by the
by the drama of his personal life and
that of his wife Edda they it was a it
was a story of was a political thriller
that happened to be true it's a story
that has sex intrigue betrayal diplomacy
war conflict and a powerful family and
personal tragedy china was a was a young
Italian diplomat and the son of a
prominent fascist when he met and
married Etta after a very brief romance
shortly after that he became Mussolini's
propaganda chief and shortly after that
he was he was named foreign minister
eeks
the youngest foreign minister in Europe
appointed at the age of 33 and initially
he was a hero worship Mussolini even
imitated his gestures and he was also
one of the most enthusiastic supporters
of the alliance with Nazi Germany but in
the summer of 1939 he discovered that
the Germans in violation of their
treaty commitments to the Italians were
getting ready to invade Poland without
any consultation with Italy and so he
came back from a meeting with with
Hitler and fun Ribbentrop in Salzburg
Austria completely disillusioned with
with the Germans and determined to
persuade Mussolini that he should break
with them
Mussolini won vacillated on this
question at times he agreed with China
at other times he he thought he had to
remain true to his own commitment and
eventually he also felt that he he
wanted to share of the Spoils Germany
came to dominate Europe so over a period
of time the relationship between
Mussolini and Chano just gradually
unraveled and China I mean I first
became interested in China or learned
about him about 35 years ago when I was
reading William Farris rise and follow
the Third Reich and I was astonished to
find this figure at the center of the
fascist apparatus who went around rather
openly calling Hitler madman and
Mussolini a fool and I thought you know
this this is an intriguing figure and I
should write a book about him well it
took me about 35 years to get around to
doing and I was surprised no no one got
on the subject before me because I
thought it was such a fascinating story
before the final break between between
the two sean-o was one of the principal
instigators of italy's invasion of
greece which which is hard to fathom
because he knew the italian military was
not prepared for a war everybody
convinced himself that he he could bribe
a few Greek officials and Italy would
have a walkover of course the war turned
into a debacle and he became the most
most hated figure I think in Italy but
in February of 1943 Mussolini removed
him as foreign minister he he had
received a intercepted K
that Hitler had sent to him cable sent
by Allen Dulles from Switzerland about
plotting against Mussolini and then
speculating that China was one of the
principal plotters so but he kept he
kept China in the government he he made
him ambassador to the Holy See and from
that point on China we can't began
actively plotting Mussolini's overthrow
none of the plots really came to
anything but miscellany got wind of all
the dissatisfaction in the party and the
fascist partying in July of 43 he called
a meeting of the fascist grand council
to clear the air he thought he could
browbeat his critics and get them to
fall in line instead he was a resolution
was adopted that it effectively stripped
Mussolini of his War Powers and China
was one of the principal speakers in
favor of the resolution so this this
meeting went on into the early hours of
the morning the next day China expected
to be arrested by Mussolini instead of
course the King had had arranged for
most Eleni to be arrested but China was
left totally isolated after after this
because first because of the debacle in
Greece which had made him unpopular and
then there were rumors that he was he
was financially corrupt and so the
people who overthrew Mussolini wanted
nothing to do with him at this point and
he was he was kept under house arrest in
his house in Rome but edia his wife who
had been pro-nazi all along still had
friends among the Germans so she
suggested that she contact them and get
the Germans to spirit them out of the
country which is what happened they
thought they were gonna fly to Spain
instead the Germans took them to to
Munich and and they were put under house
arrest there
edek came back to Italy at a certain
point and then when Mussolini was
restored to power by the Germans China
was was flown to Verona and charged with
with treason and I neglected to
mentioned earlier one of the one of the
crucial things about cha know is his
Diaries throughout his time as foreign
minister he he kept a diary which was a
highly revealing and damaging record of
the relationship between Italy and
Germany and and with revealing comments
about people like Ribbentrop and Hitler
and Mussolini so they were all aware of
this diary and they were determined that
it that did not be published
jonno had hidden hidden it in his
uncle's house in Rome so after edek came
back to Italy she she began planning to
to get the diary and get it out of the
country both the Germans were aware that
Chano had a had a weakness for the
opposite sex throughout his marriage he
and out of both had numerous affairs he
particularly her most prominent lover
was Emilio Pucci who became world famous
fashion designer after the war so the
Germans put up an SS an attractive SS
woman in in prison with Chano hoping
that in time she would be able to worm
out of him the secret of where he'd
hidden the Diaries instead she fell for
him and and she eventually helped edit
to escape to Switzerland with the
Diaries while China was was going on
trial
China was was given it was tried with
six other fascist who had voted against
Mussolini all of them except one were
condemned to death and they were taken
out of Verona to a fortress outside this
city placed on rickety wooden chair
with their backs to the firing squad
because they thought as traitors they
shouldn't be given the right to face the
squad at the last moment China turned in
his chair to to face his his assassins
Edda was also helped to escape by by
Pucci who he tore up sleeve off of a
pajama shirt put Chandos Diaries inside
it and strapped it around at his waist
to make her appear pregnant
and drove her to the Swiss border and
she crossed in the night the swiss
thought that a member of the royal
family was coming over to take refuge
and they were astonished to find who it
was when she announced her name so at a
stayed in with her children they had
also been sneaked out of the country she
stayed in switzerland for about a year
she she had a nervous breakdown and was
in an asylum and then she allan dulles
he was the american super spine in
switzerland who became course theatre
CIA director after the war eventually
made contact with her through a
correspondent for the Chicago Daily News
named Paul golly I can't prove that this
but I'm pretty sure that gali was on on
Dallas's payroll and anyway he he put
Dulles in contact with her and after a
long and difficult negotiation she
agreed to hand her and the China Diaries
over to the American government gali
meanwhile started negotiating
publication rights to the diary and
eventually the Chicago Daily News agreed
to pay Edie I think it was $25,000 which
of course was a considerable amount of
money at the time and in 1945 they
published the diary and about the full
diary in about 30 30 installments 30
days it's point are you publishing feet
edek came back to Italy after the war
and was and put in internal exile and on
the island of Li pari of the sicily
coast she was supposed to be there I
think about two years but she stayed
less than a year and then she was
allowed to have her freedom again the
government sequestered most of her
property but she eventually got back
there their apartment in Rome and she
died and she died in 1994 about the time
I started working on this book so I
never had a chance to talk to her but
she was by all accounts a rather
difficult woman who probably would not
have talked to me anyway
and that's that's basically the story so
if anybody has questions I'd be happy to
try to answer
did you ever get to see the original
diary and where did you get the pictures
like the picture yeah well there been to
two biographies of China published in
Italian the last one came out in about
1970 that particular picture came from
that book from the second of those books
and my book was first published in
Germany and most of the pictures that
are in the book were the ones that the
Germans collected from some archive in
Berlin and Yale bought them from the
same place and put them in the book well
there were three children they were
quite small when when they when their
father was a executed he had a daughter
and two sons the the older son whose
name for each Hill went to South America
eventually he had a rather he had a
rather idle life and was supposed to get
married on the eve of his wedding he he
got panicky and fled to South America
didn't come back for a while the his
younger brother never held a job drank
himself to death died at 37 and the
daughter she married after the war went
to South America with her husband they
were divorced and she came back to Rome
while my book says that she's alive in
ill health in Rome I discovered too late
that she's actually dead now but one of
the bizarre twists about the children
they were all obviously
traumatized by this whole experience in
the son who was in South America came
back to Italy at one point and while his
brother was hopeless alcoholic at this
point
he began an affair with his brother's
wife and and then took her back to South
America with him and this lasted about
three years and then she they had a
falling out she came back back to Italy
and rejoined her husband shortly before
he died so they the older the older son
wrote a book which I think it was read
solely in Italy published it was a
rather strange title when grandfather
had daddy shot which Edith thought was
in the worst possible taste
well because Chano had had she had made
a promise to her husband that she would
see it published she when she got to
Switzerland she sent letters back to
Hitler and Mussolini and said I want my
husband brought to the barren railway
station and freed and and when he's
freed I will hand over the Diaries to
you so they they tried to use it as a
bargaining chip to win his freedom but
when that when that didn't happen she
was all the more determined to see it
published she was she broke completely
with her father at the time of the trial
she went to see him several times and
begged him to to call off the trial and
he wouldn't do it and she had really
stormy scenes with him and but she was
reconciled to him before her own death
she would sometimes go to his grave and
she kept a bust of him in her apartment
that's everything she owned over
duplicato
oppose Mussolini because he developed
that Mussolini started to
was in to to Nazism for zone gains and
was not reflecting thee the aims of the
Italian people and was playing a patsy
to Hitler or was it for something a
personal like wanting to get out of the
fascist life and have a house in the
countryside well I think initially both
he and Mussolini were entranced by the
idea of being in alliance with this
great power which was going to help them
to restore the Italian Empire
Mussolini always saw himself as a modern
Caesar but eventually Chano came to
think that if the Germans dominated
Europe Italy would simply become a
vassal state of Germany and then of
course in the last year too that he was
in office he realized that the Germans
were going to lose the war so it was all
the more determined to get out but he
always saw himself as a successor to
Mussolini and so yet always hesitated to
break completely with him because he
thought eventually he could he could
take over he he had a lot of illusions
in that respect so that went into their
protection of the Jewish population well
in 1938 Mussolini adopted a series of
laws of anti-semitic laws it was done
almost certainly and purely an imitation
of what the Germans were doing but they
were never his the laws were not as
severe as anything the Germans had and
and their application of them was was
likewise I mean Chano said we had said
in his diary we have a rose water policy
toward the Jews and so there what the
Germans themselves did set up an
extermination camp near Trieste hello
toward the end the war and I possibly
Mussolini can cooperated to some extent
with that but he wasn't he wasn't really
anti-semitic I think he just didn't he
saw it as a kind of opportunist thing to
ingratiate himself with Hitler
you believe that shadow you know he saw
their gains as being one of acquisition
and the the not ceases as a domination
and that those two ideals conflicted in
solvation Parkway yeah
it's astonishing how how Mussolini made
it decisions affecting millions of
people's lives on sometimes on the basis
Pierre Lee of his jealousy of Hitler's
successes Hitler had a habit of invading
countries and sending his ambassador to
Mussolini at three o'clock in the
morning to wake him up and say hey we've
just crossed another frontier so so
Mussolini thought he'd do the same thing
with Hitler where Greece was concerned
Hitler was traveling on through France
and he then he came down to Florence to
meet Mussolini and was leaning greeted
him at the railway stations and our
troops invaded Greece this morning
Hitler was not at all pleased and of
course he eventually had to send his own
forces to Greece to bail out the
Italians which which contributed to his
defeat in Russia because he had to
divert troops there that he would
otherwise abused in the invasion of
Russia
how much do you think China's politics
I heard directly
I don't think they were influenced by
her very much at all he he seemed to
have a rather condescending attitude
toward her political views I mean you
get this from his Diaries she came to
see him once and was pushing a Nazi line
and he said it's she was kept going to
Florence to a musical festival he wrote
his Diaries better than at Florence that
edit go to Florence and to the music
festival where she's something she's
more capable of dealing with something
words to that effect
but when Hitler first they were in China
together when Hitler first came to power
and she said how wonderful and he said
what a disaster she maintained this
pro-nazi line all along I think he was
influenced probably more by his circle
of friends he he spent a lot of time at
a golf club outside Rome and his friends
were all virtually all pro English
pro-american and I think he was
influenced a lot by them particular
after he started to become disillusioned
with Mussolini
very kindly up in the beginning by the
America
well what was the American and what was
the English in
I don't think they they took China all
that seriously they just saw this as a
nepotistic appointment when he was made
foreign minister and Joseph Kennedy
President Kennedy's father who was
ambassador to the UK came to Rome one
point and described Chano as a pompous
ass said that he was only interested in
chasing women which is a bit rich coming
from Joseph Kennedy do you think that
Johnno thought he might be able to
convince I was leaning before he tried
to do
convinced him to break from it to change
his boss nazar to take a better look at
let's go yeah I think I mean he tried
for a very long while to to get him to
do that I think he never quite a Bandhan
hoped that this would happen but at
about from about 1940 on I would say he
started passing word to the to the
Allies about you know about Mussolini's
policies things even you know
practically treasonable things that he
would say say to them and Sumner Welles
who was the American Undersecretary of
state came to came to Rome in that
period he was sent by President
Roosevelt to try to head off war and was
Mussolini was in Shawano were going to
up to the Brenner pass to meet Hitler
and Chano said to Welles he said stick
around another couple of days until I
get back from the meeting with Hitler
and I can fill you in on what happened
so he did of course this would have cost
him his head right there did this been
been known
he had to some of his friends tried to
get him to leave the country and they
had various stages in Heath he refused
to do it and even even when he was under
house arrest in Rome his I mean somebody
came to him told him that his personal
pilot would happily fly him to Spain but
it would mean going alone and he said no
I'm not going to leave ahead of my
children so it was a foolish decision
because nothing serious would have
happened to them but he would have
gotten away and they could have been
reignited eventually but didn't happen
anybody else well of course the Mafia
has always been credited with with
playing a role in in helping preparing
the way for the Allied invasion of
Sicily so Mussolini
Mussolini had done a lot to suppress the
mafia but they were still around and
they they were active in that respect
Oh
so nobody yes it's my daughter
well that's a good question because
ultimately his opposition to Mussolini
came to nothing so yeah I think things
whether he had been there not things
would worked out pretty much as they did
okay great okay well I thank you all for
coming I'm delighted